In this lesson, we learn that when and where a gene is expressed matters a lot.
>> Lactase expression is present in nearly
all babies and slows over time. However,
if you're one of the people who
has the allele that keeps lactase expression high.
>> Now all the differences in the different cell types of your body
have to do with these kinds of differences in the activity of gene products.
>> Every cell in your body has the exact
same instructions. They just read different parts at different
times, depending on the coordination between the coding and non-coding regions.
>> Now, what we've learned in this lesson and the
three lessons previous are really important for us to build
on in the following lessons. So if you've had trouble
with this material or material before this, I want you to
go back watch some of those videos again, take some
of the problem sets, go to the forums and talk to
some of the other students. Because it's really important that
you have a firm understanding of this material before moving forward.
>> Now, in the meantime, next time you
reach for that glass of milk and cookies
>> Think twice about how that amazing human
evolution has allowed you to enjoy this yummy drink.